bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video che sono pochi j
oggi andiamo avanti sul craven manor
eravamo rimasti raga che è praticamente
avevamo scoperto sto passaggio di sotto
che non so bene dove porta praticamente
raga mi avete detto che per proseguire
non ci sarei mai arrivato è in pratica
devo all'amico roma ok perfetto
devo riuscire a costruirvi un percorso
con le stanze permette devo prendere le
stanze queste qui è e metterle tipo come
se dovessi fare un percorso per
arrivarci tipo così la cosa brutta è che
io da piccolo non cioè non sono mai
stato bravo coi puzzle non finivano
anche quelli a due pezzi
quindi o il casi allora innanzitutto
facciamo così mettiamo questi ok
perfetto allora piano
proviamo a costruire allora il primo
pezzo sembra essere questo
ok forse ci siamo il primo lo azzeccato
andiamo con non è difficile raga proia
sono impedito il secondo sembra essere
questo ok forse ci siamo
forse ci siamo se ce l'ha fatta
ok raga abbiamo creato il il passaggio
perfetto
adesso adesso dovrebbe se tutto allora
ma qua combacia cos'è estero perché blu
perché blu questa è normale
sì direi che è normale perché non si
spostano quindi va bene adesso ragazze
tutto è andato come previsto a
dovrebbero essersi sbloccata e tutte le
già premente yacht
tornando nella porta di prima dovrei c'è
praticamente dovrei esami creato una
strada con tutte le ok è aperta è già
aperta non mi piace questa cosa che è
già aperta comunque è però va bene
andiamo avanti avete visto qualcosa che
vuoi
c'era qualcosa di cazzo c'era qua io non
sono pazzo non sono pazzo
c'era qualcosa qui dietro siamo bloccati
ma che cazzo sono sti rumori che ogni
tanto si sente sentito ragazzi io vado
avanti a abbiate pazienza e volevo farvi
notare che quando attaccate le stanze
quando attaccò le stanze in modo da da
creare il ponte si sballa sta tutto c'è
qua prima era tutto in piedi era perché
ora è sì e scombussolato tutto va bene
direi di andare avanti buongiorno con
lester zakelj min parco queste giacche
dini in blu perfetto questa in red
cosa mi rappresenta sta merda emma bell
arcobaleno fantastico se questo lei è
uno che mente in poche parole va beh
cosa è un libro questo è qua c'è il
mondo raga una volta era nell'entrata
adesso c'è è finito qui non si sa come
se ne michael jordan michael giorno
ancora lui il tiro no kat
c'ero quasi va beh direi di andare
avanti al [ __ ] a palla e questa non
si apre fantastico già non doveva andare
così come mai non sia dovuto fare
qualcosa tipo a si vede che ha la palla
magari devo metterla veramente in si
cosi cosa cazzo è successo mi sono dato
una botta assurda e sono in fin di vita
sono in fin di vita la porta è chiusa
probabilmente non la dovevo mettere qui
perfetto
raga non so cosa devo fare vede che a
che fare con cecchelin il rainbow
comunque va bene allora la gazza chelini
blu dice che il verde sta mentendo
ma jaqueline in verde dice che la palla
deve essere nel posto che a destra
però è anche vero che già chelini in
bianco dice che il blu è onesto è il blu
infatti dice che il verde sta mentendo
però quella rossa dice che si deve
trovare nel terzo posto a partire da
sinistra
però è anche vero che quella viola dice
che deve trovarsi nel posto più a
sinistra ma quella gialla dice che
quella viola sta dicendo la verità
quindi ragazzi conclude che gli orsi
vanno in letargo d'inverno perché le
puntate di grey's anatomy ci sono
soltanto d'estate
quindi dopo questa perla di saggezza
direi che la via giusta è quella destra
e ho sbagliato a vera gara dato che la
mia capacità di ragionamento equivale a
quella di un cactus direi di tirare a
sorte due sono già andati ne rimangono
due vediamo se riesco a sbagliare anche
il penultimo così siamo a posto ma
questa era giusta ce l'abbiamo fatta e
chi è chi diceva la verità la verità è
che il savoiardo va cotto al forno
perfetto andiamo avanti
chiudiamo la porta e ci siamo raga
perche perche si è impiccato
senti zio non me lo avevi detto che
volevi farla finita
veramente mi dispiace tantissimo mi
dispiace cazzo mi dispiace o banca arner
star va bene direi che ci siamo cazzo
cos'è o mio dio e da dove sono spuntati
questi
bene noi li avevo visti e sentiti un
secondo è io avevo visto sei stato tu
vero dorian sei stato tu
è colpa di dorian gray vabbè comunque
andiamo avanti allora di qua ci deve
essere una strada raga non so bene dove
ma ci deve essere una strada nascosta
bene allora non mi ricordo cosa è
successo si è mosso letto fantastico ok
raga passaggio segreto epico passaggio
segreto epico direi di andare madonna
amo sempre di più questo gioco e hanno
sempre di più le cantine oscure l'ultima
volta è stato un trauma caso va beh
direi di andare avanti permette sky che
cazzo il successo c'è stato un flash
organismo cos'è cos'è cos'è harry potter
che si esercita con l'uomo che cazzo è
expelliarmus ce ne sono non c'è che cosa
chi cazzo è cosa è successo oddio cos'è
sta roba
senti merlino che cazzo stai cos'è raga
non so che cos'era quella roba non ne ho
idea
ma andiamo avanti di qua e odio così
voltati che morbido è sto cazzo morbido
va beh direi di andare avanti e c'è
anche una cosa è quello l'ordine dei
quattro toni sembra essere sembra avere
un significato magari posso provare a
ricreare lo stesso rumore ha la stessa
melodia dei dei vetri quale melodia che
cazzo di melodia steri c'è devo tirare
la leva
[Musica]
ok allora un haga l'ordine è quello lì
però il problema che non ho capito che
sono i fan ostico da faccia allo studio
ma [ __ ]
che ne so io vabbè allora questa qui c'è
il simbolo dell'infinito quindi c'è più
o meno le l'infinito quindi è quello il
terzo ok allora devo dare per scontato
che quello che questo qui è il terzo
quindi qualsiasi cosa devo fare io
quello lo butto per terzo allora vai
così no infatti ho sbagliato nel mancato
il centro cazzo c'è un pozzo di due
metri
vai così ok il primo l'ho preso e quello
blu allora raga il primo è quello blu
quello rosso non va bene quindi questo
verde ok
vai così se ci siamo abbiamo anche il
secondo
allora questo qui vai per esclusione e
ci dovremmo essere ok raga l'ultimo il
rosso ci siamo
vai cos'è ok adesso non scassare un gas
ce l'ho fatta vado su e vado vado su si
apre la porta si è aperta sia aperta la
porta
ringraziando iddio incredibile allora
chiudiamo sta roba che già non ne posso
più
ciao dorian tutto a posto e sentiti io
devo andare avanti o scusami se ti
lascio qui eh va beh direi di andare
avanti allora andiamo apriamo st porta
qui andiamo avanti nato qui così si sono
impiccati allora perfetto c'è cos'è star
ragazzi sembra cos'è sta roba
va beh direi di andare alla madonna raga
st cos'è un labirinto degli specchi sta
roba che è successo dio cosa cazzo sta
succedendo cos'è sta roba è un portale
che cos'è è un labirinto no che figo è
un labirinto degli specchi allora
veramente io ho un pessimo ricordo di
quando ero piccolo costi cosi perchè ci
aveva sbattuto il naso non avevo visto
un metro a si alza questo proprio
innovativa la cosa fanta cos'è cos'è
perché c'è del sangue ma che cazzo fanta
cos'è una se ho mio dio perché sono
finito da saw l'enigmista
ma che cazzo nino ogni gioco horror da
adesso in avanti c'è l'enigmista non c'è
verso se no
anche prima in mare c'era l'enigmista è
ormai ovunque noi andiamo avanti
ugualmente io qui non la voglia di
torturare nessuno cos'è cosa sta su
cos'è sta roba cosa raga che cosa cazzo
è è una palla da discoteca dobbiamo
ballare
vabbè io vado vado avanti anche perché
qui non so che cosa sta succedendo cosa
cazzo sta succedendo
raga sta diventando peggio ogni volta
che vado avanti non ho ben capito
sinceramente qual è il mio obiettivo ma
io sto continuando ad andare avanti e ce
n'è la roba qui a te c'è un braccio
hanno torturato la statua quarto ragazzo
ci godo non c'è più la strada qui sono
rimasto bloccato
eh no veramente qua adesso sono rimasto
via di questo aiuto scappa cazzo scatto
giusto stronzo aiutami ecco io oggi ho
visto plum ai cuori bastardo corri corri
io aiuto cazzo ti aspetta la luce è
merda come faccio compresero pre
sorpresa aiuto aiuto bastardo che mi
stop a [ __ ] a ok brutto bastardo a
noi due
mai così ce la posso fare cosa sta
facendo
ayew che è successo ce l'ho fatta non so
come cazzo fatto ma ce l'ho fatta se non
ci credo ragazza e cazzo succede si sta
smaterializzando tutto sono partiti
metrica madonna sta crollando tutto naga
via via di qui run run nuovo capito che
dovevo guardare grazie mille
anche senza la scritta c'era arrivato è
troppo buio via di qui torniamo indietro
dorian se a posto cazzo è successo un
disastro poi ti racconto è stata tanto è
porca [ __ ] con rivi sa cosa sta
succedendo
la gestione tutto cazzo come cazzo si
esce di ba porca [ __ ] via via via via
via via via via chiamati i pompieri fate
qualcosa
raga c'era una leva qui una volta dove
cazzo è dove prima che crolli tutto
caffè col ecco l'hanno trovata cazzo che
culo via via via via via via via via via
porca [ __ ]
no dove l'altro l'ex già possiamo tira
tira cazzo una leva porca [ __ ] un po
perché festa va giù ma le altre normali
ce n'è un'altra ci sono quante cazzo di
neve ci sono porca [ __ ] ce n'era uno
strap dai cazzo a presenti abbiamo
quarto dopo un ora sta crollando tutto
apriti cazzo se ce la dobbiamo fare vai
così non è più a fuoco mai così meglio
meglio meglio perché il letto è più
spostato zio crolla tutto
no non mi dire che è chiusa non rompere
il cazzo tuo già che sta crollando tutto
dati ci metterebbero il suo brutto
bastardo
cos'è questo un'altra vai vai brutto
stronzo di controne a me
mai così è
pecca di questa bastardo ce lo fa con
dio di nuovo ma che cazzo perché devi
rompere i [ __ ] anche quando la roba
da fuoco
no merda si è aperta la porta almeno di
temi che sia fatta la porta mai la porta
in fiamme porca [ __ ] non c'è verso
oddio sono caduto giù che è successo via
via via via via via di qua via di pavia
di gioia di vivere le fiere in cui prima
che finiamo sepolti vivi
cosa dobbiamo fare qua non c'è chi o
cosa in ascensore sta roba fatemi capire
cos'è cosa cazzo sta studio con dio
vai vai vai vai airline ok ok piano o
mio dio
cosa sa cosa sta succedendo ai gas checa
mio dio ma qualcuno mi spieghi ceca
passoni importa fatemi capire mai così
già stiamo facendo
ce la possiamo fare mai come faccio a
saltare un salto raga scaffali che
ballano muoviamoci quando la vostra vita
appesa un filo
io ce l'ho appesa ai libri cazzo mai
così vai così va così
apriti apriti non so dove forti ma
aprite che stiamo vicino all'uscita
siamo vicini alla fortuna uscita o dio
perché c'è l'occhio di sauron merda mi
stava e call cos'è sta roba mi spiegate
che cazzo sta succedendo è un boss
raga c'è il boss finale da battere pavia
presto poi penso sia il primo boss se io
sto sto affrontando un po se sto
parlando
penso sia il primo boss che affronto da
quando c'è da quando aperto il canale
non ho mai affrontato niente quindi
ragazzi per la prima volta provincia i
versus boss ti faccio il culo bastardo
dove sei sta facendo il culo devono
beccare quella roba lì ok perfetto
capitola che devo applicare sta roba
il problema è che non so come arriva ho
capito ho capito vai domandargli sopra
devo andare di soft maledizione cordi
brutto peso corri raga devo fare lo
slalom qui sarà pronto a mandare la
qualche parte c'è la fossa allora devo
beccare variety che culo ok perfetto
come non detto mi ha preso in faccia
piena ma ce la posso fare
quanti ce ne sono ancora città colpire
di si cosi non penso forse l'unico
infatti eccone un altro cui ce n'è un
altro vai vai vai vai vai vai colpiscimi
stronzo colpiscimi recami brutto stronzo
beckham è vecchia di questo ht questo
cazzo
ok come non detto meglio che l'aspetto
di fare [ __ ] che prima o poi verrà
mi ammazza veramente facciamo figura di
merda vabbè
dove dove sta l'ultimo ce ne sarà un
altro un terzo credo dove cazzo
eccoli soft lo vedo dov'è perché mi
becca porca [ __ ] vai così vai con lo
slalom prova a colpirmi pregio di jackie
chan cazzo schivo tutto
vai così val cos'è che ci siamo mai che
ci siamo colpiscimi ce l'abbiamo fatta
non l'ha preso porca [ __ ] vice sono
qui mi vedi vive di dritto grip perfetto
ok ce l'abbiamo fatto non ci credo se
primo tentativo sia aperto la porta
cos'è quello il sole
no perché non mi stupirei di pasticcio
sud est europa
un buco nero ciao torni a trovarci
perfetto è tutto ok ce la stiamo facendo
ragazzi sta risucchiando tutto sta roba
è
bene sono vivo io c'ho capito centrali
cazzo mi si è schiantato una piastra
addosso ok mi sto risvegli cos'è e cosa
mi sto risvegliando sono sono vivo sono
ancora oddio perché sono tornato
indietro no perché sono il suo posto di
merda porca [ __ ]
no non mi dite che sono di nuovo qui no
io non me la rifaccio tutta ma siete
paper che è pieno di test non è che sono
diventato un manichino fatemi capire
bene sono di nuovo no dai ragazzi ma
veramente sono di nuovo qui oddio lo
sono diventato veramente un manichino
non ci credo ma no cazzo a buongiorno
ragazze ma è finito qui raga finisce
così ci sono rimasto di merda finale
siamo diventati dei fottuti manichini
ragazzo è stato spettacolare l'indie più
adrenalinico di sempre questo senza
dubbio è stato uno spettacolo ragazzi
ricordatevi che questa comunque un alfa
avessero e completa uscirà e la farò di
sicuro perché veramente epico vabbè
comunque raga direi che per oggi posso
concludere qui sei video è piaciuto
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook come non i video
trovate nella descrizione 06 da con i
siti iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo le
pressioni
ragazzi
[Musica]